don't be nervous when you pass this test
you are a high school graduate okay go
get him public school is just an
institution for low expectations a home
school let me walking through those
doors is gonna change my life forever
like some supernova explosion of love
I need my test back you failed you
failed home school it's kind of time for
me to maybe go to public school my name
is Liam Heep I'm here to win over the
one-legged girl well new kid on the
block
with girls and just they dicks and I'm
gonna be Anastasia's dick
[Music]
hold the telephone you're rebelling
that's what this is
what are outlets that teens were belt
with swearing skipping school getting my
nose pierced no way no way that is
permanent
hey kid you want some candy this is a
supervised first try it's Bernie it's
Bernie Sanders she likes you what does
that mean for me not good for you
forget about school it's time to party
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I feel like a pretty cool kid you have a
very cool mother
[Music]
you
you